las vegas was home to the stars last
week during cinemacon the largest
gathering for the worldwide motion
picture industry and it took place right
here at caesars palace las vegas now was
the only local station to get the scoop
on what movies are headed to the big
screen take a look hollywood took over
las vegas at cinemacon and the stars
were out to talk about the new comedy
about my father based loosely on the
life of comedian sebastian maniscalco we
didn't broadcast our problems my
father's like [ __ ] don't tell nobody
what's going on in here this year's
cinema verity award honoree robert de
niro tells us what it was like getting
into the role of playing sebastian's
father it was fun his father's
uh an interesting guy i
i like him i understand him
certain elements about
him and his character made it easier for
me
just to have fun with it
and uh sebastian was great the director
laura caruso is italian-american
she understands the world if you will so
it was nice also starring alongside de
niro is leslie bibb what's it like
working alongside robert de niro
sebastian miniscalco
i don't know i feel really lucky and it
was very easy to go to work every day
john wick chapter 4 isn't set to hit
theaters until 2023 but it promises a
lot of turned up action john wick action
turned up
um wonderful new characters world
building
surprises a lot of surprises
that's all we can say scales in a little
bit
going to france going to berlin
oh my gosh a little bit of everything
from action to a coming-of-age story
rachel mcadams is ready to do judy bloom
proud as she takes on a special role in
the new film are you there god it's me
margaret i think it's a timeless story i
think it's still important to
you know we're all still struggling with
who we are and what we're doing here
no matter what age you are so um and
it's just got so much heart and humor in
it and um it's an event for judy bloom
to to have a book of hers adapted she
doesn't do it very often so it's very
special her co-star and cinemacon rising
star of 2022 abby ryder-fortson was
thrilled to work alongside mcadam she's
amazing she's such an incredible person
to look up to as a role model and as an
actress you don't have to wait long
though to see rachel mcadams on the big
the doorway screen universes
we don't know who or what will walk
through it you're reprising your role
also in doctor strange everyone is so
excited to see it but i gotta ask you in
addition to that if you could reprise
any other role that you've done what
would it be
i feel like i need a little more regina
george in my life oh yeah she'd be fun
she'd be fun i'd like to see reaching in
her 40s let's see what's happening there
i really loved playing um
a cop in true detective that was a fun
character a dark but
but fun maybe kind of an alter ego yeah
sure
well rachel congratulations on
everything we can't wait to see the
movie and enjoy the rest of your time in
vegas let's give a little wave to vegas
here hey vegas nice to see you the real
star of the weekend though was our city
itself
yeah no but like friendship and like
camaraderie and then
and then uh yeah
i feel like there's a little more to
that story but i won't make it
we love seeing you out here magus you
just give us a little vegas love to the
camera right here
we'll take it
hey we got a hello from robert de niro
we will take it the only local station
in cinema con you did such an excellent
job tell me thank you what was it like
standing that close to keanu reeves oh
you had to take a moment
this is a
beautiful man and a talented man and he
was just so nice and down to earth
rachel mcadams is the sweetest person in
the world i was just living my life you
know when you have a moment you're like
how is this work yeah we were just
hanging out with the coolest people and
it was great and they have a lot of
exciting movies to come in the next year
well you did an excellent job on that
red carpet loved every minute of that
well staying on the